in this video i'm going to talk about
how to scale your company by scaling
through hiring all right so if you guys
don't know how to do these two things
that i'm going to be walking through uh
i will show you how to scale in the
realest way all right like this is from
the trenches
so if you guys don't know who i am my
name is alex rozio at acquisition.com we
do about 85 million a year in revenue
and i have nothing to sell you all right
so uh first time i heard this term uh
was from a guy named alex tarfin and
this is uh
his in his external framework and i want
to show you my internal framework for
scaling the company on the inside all
right and so um he talks about how
there's there's five he calls them core
functions of the business right so
you've got lead generation
you've got lead nurture which is working
the leads to get them to to show
you've got sales
you've got fulfillment and then you've
got retention and ascension right so
retention getting people to buy more
times essentially getting to buy more
expensive stuff right so he calls these
the five core functions right of any
business etc i remember looking at this
and being like oh this is so cool and
these are the things that uh you should
really never outsource in your business
it's my opinion right you should know
how to generate leads you should know
how to work the leads you know how to
sell you should not have fulfill and you
just know how to uh retain and ascend
your customers right if you don't know
how to do these things and you haven't
divided up your uh the activities of the
business into this thing it's a very
useful framework that you can use for
yourself all right and think about this
as a pipeline right that's everything
here is done in sequence but here's the
cool thing there is a parallel
internal five core functions of a
business that you can use and that you
should use and when i realized this this
is what allowed us to scale our business
because we actually were able to use the
same methodology the same thinking
process of how we scaled our acquisition
of getting more customers and continuing
to grow that side to how we scale our
employees and how we get them alright so
follow along so what normally externally
we're doing is lead generation here
we're doing is application generation so
this is how we're getting and the ads
that we're running where we're running
them and just like you can run an ad to
get a prospect you can run an ad to get
an employee just like you can do cold
outbound to get a client you can use
cold outbound to recruit from other
companies you can use code outbound to
attract talent all right so the same six
ways of getting customers also works
when you're actually getting employees
all right so think about this hopefully
this is a good mindset shift for you so
there's six ways of getting customers
i'll see them real quick you can do paid
ads you can do earned media so if you
have a following of any kind you can
have your own media so people you
already have access to on your lists
your your crm your cell phone the people
who follow you uh that that have given
you access to them right that you can
directly message them without asking
their permission the fourth is through
manual outbound the fifth is through
affiliates and the sixth is through word
of mouth right there's the six ways you
get customers right that is all of these
things are traffic for how you generate
leads
but you can also use those same six
for how you generate applications pretty
cool right because right now all of us
are one amazing hire away from all the
growth you could ever want and i promise
you that i've lived this firsthand is
that a lot of times you don't need a
what you need a who right you're trying
to find and figure out the skill when
someone already has that skill and the
experience and has already run an
olympic gold multiple times you just say
hey can you just run it over here rather
than trying to figure it all out on your
own it's much faster and simpler all
right so just like you have lead
generation you have application
generation
what goes next application nurture all
right so there's some really interesting
stats along this but 10 out of 10
employees high quality prospects will
find a job within eight days so if it
takes you six days to even make your
first contact with the the leads that
you're getting from applications which
honestly happens so common people work
the crap out of their leads but don't
completely ignore the applications that
are coming in for new employees right
you should have just as structured of a
process of how you're nurturing those
applications so that they have a high
likelihood of scheduling and showing up
for
wait for it instead of sales are you
still selling hell yeah you're still
selling but we just call it interviewing
right and so we're selling them on why
they should work for us right rather
than someone else and right now more
than ever before is a huge war for
talent all right all the companies that
i know of and all the guys who have
bigger companies right now are all
talking about it is that the the
the drive to acquire talent is higher
now than it ever has been it's because
of the shift to remote so now everyone
is competing against netflix apple
google like all these huge companies are
now fishing in all of our ponds because
they're employing remotely right and so
what used to be an advantage if you you
know worked from home or you had an
internet business is no is now just
table stakes work from home flexible
hours etc is now table stakes right and
so now we have to get more aggressive
and more deliberate in how we recruit
and hire and that's the only way that
you scale your company it's the only way
once you increase this side
you have to increase this side because
you have to accommodate the demand that
you're meeting i said there's five core
functions these are the external ones
these are the internal now who can guess
what number four is right you have
fulfillment for your customers
but now you have training for your
employees you take the person who now
says yes and you make sure that they now
go through the process which as a
customer would be fulfilling before an
employee is fulfilling on the job you
just sold them on right and so you're
actually giving them the skills and how
you function and how you do things
within your company what are the
communication cadences who are they
going to report to what is the job
description where the kpis are going to
be measured on you know what their
compensation structure is how they can
get raises all that kind of stuff and so
that's the fourth thing that has to be
defined within your internal pipeline
that are that are core functions of the
business now number five who can guess
what this is normally you have retention
and ascension sorry my camera's just
being wacky as hell i try to keep it try
to keep it fun for you guys mix it up
try and uh go in and out of focus number
five
is how are you going to retain
and ascend
your talent how are you going to retain
them so how you're going to continue to
motivate them so that they want to
continue to perform that's the retention
aspect and then how do we select the
star players and ascend them to higher
levels and put them on a fast track so
that they can move up within the company
and get more responsibility and make
more impact to the bottom line in the
business how can you identify the
leaders early on and then put them on a
track that allows them to grow which is
one of the biggest things that if you
see the biggest companies in the world
it's because they have such amazing
talent acquisition systems and retention
and ascension systems for identifying
talent and allowing them to move up all
right the reason the biggest companies
in the world are the biggest companies
the world is because they employ the
smartest people i mean think about this
if you find out that somebody worked at
facebook or they worked at google at in
any kind of relatively high up capacity
you're going to probably assume that
that person's very smart right so think
about that kind of brand
for your own business how can i make it
so that my business becomes a a star or
a stamp of approval on someone's revenue
someone's resume how can i make it so
that my business is like harvard man and
i can tell you there's definitely
aspects of our business if someone like
the amount of people who try and recruit
my sales team is ridiculous right but we
pay really well so it's hard and they
also really like it here because we're
you know established business and they
have a clear career path they can make
lots of money but the thing is is that
if you can create this thing where
people aspire to be associated with your
brand and your company then they will
retain you will be able to track better
people they will want to work for you
because they'll know that your your
training your fulfillment right that you
have
is so good
that it's worth even taking a pay cut to
acquire the skills through the business
that you have because you're so good at
teaching it right these skills that make
them more valuable and so i wanted to
give you this as two parallel frameworks
that you can use within your business
one is the external framework of lead
generation lead nurture sales
fulfillment retention and ascension of
how you bring people in to your business
and then there's a parallel or a mirror
internal core functions of how you get
generate you generate applications you
uh nurture those applications so that
they schedule and they show up for
interviews you sell them during the
interview so you should have a process a
script just like you have a sales script
you have a sales script internally how
you can indoctrinate people once they
come in to believe what you believe
share the values that you have and then
hopefully just like in a normal sale
disqualify people that aren't going to
be a good fit and then once they are in
fulfill on the promises that you made to
them increase the value of that person
show them how they can fit and provide
value to the company and then finally
how do we what are the kpis that we use
to manage these people what are they
driving towards what are they going to
get compensated and then how do we
ascend them what are the titles that
they that they get and what are the
increases in pay that are clear based on
milestones when they know they will
qualify for that next raise or for that
next increase in job so they can see a
clear path of when they're going to work
and continue to work for your company
because if they have no way they can't
see a future for when they're going to
work for you they're ticking time bomb
for when they're going to leave you for
someone else all right and so talent is
the way that you scale the business and
if you don't have a reliable way and you
don't know the metrics of your talent
acquisition system well then is it any
wonder why you don't have the talent
that you want
so i'll leave you with that in terms of
how to scale the business like i said
mosey nation there's lots of people who
are broke i don't want you to be one of
them that's why i make these videos keep
being awesome i'll see you guys in the
next bit bye